là ça fait un moment que je reçois selon
d' insulte je ne peux plus donc ça doit
s'arrêter
[Musique]
salut tout le monde alors si vous voulez
rire j'en ai une bonne pour vous
aujourd'hui hier au boulot donc à la
météo
il ya une dame qui a appelé pour dire
que j'étais trop noire et qu'elle ne
voyait rien dans l'écran qu'on ne voyait
que mes vêtements que je ne passais pas
bien la télé parce que j'étais trop noir
et qu'il fallait me le dire
ça me fait délirer d'imaginer cette
espèce de dames chez elle et qui se dit
enfin voir telle est la dame est métro
noir je ne vois rien je viens pour les
leurres météo faut le dire
c'est absurde donc je suis partagé entre
le rire entre la colère parce que en
fait ça commence à ça commence à
vraiment m'énerver ce genre de message
je reçois ce ça ne s'arrête pas ça va
faire un an que je fais ce métier
maintenant et j'en ai marre en fait de
recevoir des tonnes de messages racistes
des messages insultants
donc ça commence à mettre en colère
vraiment et puis ça me touche 4 aux gens
qui pensent que le racisme en belgique
n'existe pas c'est pas vrai des gens
racistes dijon des misogynes la
discrimination tout ça ça doit s'arrêter
donc maintenant je vais en parler je
vais dénoncer je vais le dire on a eu
balances ton port maintenant on va voir
balances ton qu'on d'accord on va
balancer des combats valence et les gens
qui qui qui qui qui qui sont trop fermé
d'esprit et ibug et en blessent d'autres
ça doit s'arrêter le harcèlement sur les
réseaux sociaux l'harcèlement virtuel
c'est ça touche les gens qui sont
peut-être plus faibles que moi et qui le
vivent moins bien et et et et voilà et
j'ai envie d'aider zon de personnes j'ai
envie peut-être grâce à ma médiatisation
d'aider certaines personnes qui n'arrive
peut-être pas à à dire tous les
persécutions qu'elles vivent les
discriminations qu'elles vivent et les
oppressions et maintenant voilà six 6
mois je peux aider ces gens là a à dire
les choses allons-y
faisons le ensemble mais maintenant ça
va savoir tous les messages que je
reçois tous ces trucs insultant je vais
les balancer et à vous qui compte
mais à m'écrire ce genre de saloperie
sachez que là ça me touche parce que là
je suis mon parce que ce que j'en peux
plus parce que je fatigue et mais vous
me rendais plus forte hockey et si vous
n'en pouvait plus de voir ma gueule à la
télé vous n'êtes pas prêts de plus voir
ma gueule à la télé
[Musique]
moi je me sens belge
je me sens belle je suis bien dans mon
pays nous faut maintenant on va arrêter
de me dire de rentrer dans mon pays
parce que je suis dans mon pays d'accord
ou maman on arrête les messages racistes
et si tu es trop raciste et si tu si tu
sais pas quoi faire de deux talents glas
de ton de ton pc tu arrêtes tu te jette
toi fais autre chose en sais rien tu
touche déjà le fonds reste au fond mais
laisse les gens tranquilles toi et ton
petit esprit